Oh my god, I'm so fucking late. I'm so sorry I was recording ASMR. Bodlings! I promise I'm
here as well, Bodling. Okay? I don't even have a cup of tea! I don't even have a cup of tea!
Hold on, let me open up the bottle. Oh my god, I'm so sorry. I'm so fucking sorry.
You can tell with the vomit in there, honestly. I'm sorry, thank you for
going to put on me such a thing. Oh god, that's really bad, thank you.
Okay, okay, model up, model up. Okay, and then put the lay on. I'm so sorry. No, what the
minute? What the minute? I'm so sorry. I just recorded ASMR like right there. I recorded,
I did not realise how long I rambled for. I recorded an ASMR shot and then I recorded
an ASMR video where I was showing you how I record ASMR. So it was like ASMR inception.
I'm so sorry. I'm so, so sorry. Can you hear me testing? I'm so sorry. Okay, right. I don't think
I need to recalibrate my model. It looks like it's too interesting. Okay, right. I'm so sorry. I
just recorded like a 30-minute handcam ASMR video though. I'm gonna send it away to the editors
so there's gonna be a lot of content, okay? Right, let me put watermelon away. What the
melon? Wait, oh no, watermelon's in the beach of studio with me. Watermelon, I'm sorry, but
it's not cool. Oh, you can hear the game? You can hear the game? Oh, it's very loud. Oh, okay. Slime
Rancher is in a pre-release stage. Wait, it's not even finished. I thought it was finished.
We can hear it loud and clear. Okay, I've lowered the desktop volume. A very small percent,
epileptic seizures. Oh, yeah. What kind of game are we getting in? Epileptic seizures.
It's early access, but it's not really early access. No, I'm...
Okay, so just as a quick tip, but I've never played any Slime Rancher game. I have no idea
what it's about in terms of I've seen someone put slimes in a cage. So I'm gonna just say the slimes
are the reeflings that escape the farm and I need to go get you. Slime girl time, you wish.
You wish I was getting a slime girl. It's no happening, let it go. Save icon, little... Oh,
can I get a green one? Oh, one for reefling, no green one. Uh-huh. Oh, I'm gonna put my col...
Right, fine, I'll put my collar on. Hold on, let me take that as well. I can put it on. Oh, sorry,
you just let me click it. Thank you for the tip. Fine, the collar goes on. As if I'm not supposed
to put a collar on you because we're in the fucking farm today. I'm bringing you back to the farm.
At work, I can't wear mine. No. Game is a bit too loud. Right, let me turn that shit down.
Let me turn the background down there. I turned it down by five decibels.
You sell the... I sell reefling poop. Damn, the ASMR game, we're really struggling out here.
Oh, why am I lagging? Excuse me, don't lag again, do you understand me? Is there a green icon save?
Oh, there's not one green one, fine. We'll put Snuffy on it. Tutorial enabled, yes. Tar. Tar are
unruly creatures that sometimes spawn in the world are granted. They will damage the player,
spoil food, and devour other slimes. Disabling can reduce difficulty, I'll survive. Feral slimes
appear in small numbers of locations in the world. They're a bit grumpy and will often damage the
player. They're setting enables or decibels or... Nope, that's fine. Modifies the damage received
to the player. Receiving can reduce difficulty while increasing it. Oh, the smallest I can do
is point five. I'm going to be honest, I didn't want to play this game for the first time and get
soft locks. I'm here to collect slimes, I don't know about you. Suck up the good slime and make
it long. Put with a bit of a majome, anation. Let's just make it ink, you. Oh, lore. After a long day
of slime wrenching, Beatrix LeBeau was enjoying a cool glass of carrot juice as she watched the
sunset across the slime scene. Suddenly, a boat arrived at her dock with nothing inside but a
mysterious letter. What do you think then? You have explored the far far region range range
from the dusty shores of the dry reef to the furthest reaches of the perilous glass desert.
But there are well yet uncharted Beatrix LeBeau. Rainbow Island awaits you, climb aboard if you're
ready for a new adventure. Okay. Beatrix excitedly boarded the boat and it took her across the slime
sea. Eventually, she saw an oil and unlike anything on the far, far range mountains, trees and
grasses, all in an array of colors that danced and moved like a dream.
How will you read it if she's Scottish? As she explored, she found an abandoned conservatory
overlooking the rest of the island. Curiously, it was equipped with everything a slime
wrencher like her would ever need to wrangle slime, start a farm and build gadgets.
And so a new adventure begins. Beatrix tightened her boots, readied her backpack and set out to
explore Rainbow Island and uncover its mysteries. And just really lovely. What is this trace that
Theresa here? Ever get that feeling? A deja vu? Whoa, my PC can't handle this. What? Right, WASD.
Right, stop slime pedia. No, calm down. Frame rate? Can I be that? I can't be the frame rate.
Go and put it like, what are these? No, right, hold on. This is absolutely caca. Right, go easy.
Yeah, low, do low. Right, apply, apply. Thank you because I don't know why the PCs act
unlike it's having a stroke. The only one having a stroke in here is me. Right, jump and sprint.
Oh my god, I love a good game. Jump and sprint, jump and sprint, jump and sprint. I'm on my
Harry's land. Oh my god, why? I'm just going to say it's loading in asset packs. How do you
vac like a rancher? Your vac pack can vac things up and store them in the tank. I assume you.
Okay, we have obtained our first slave, the first refling slave for the farm. Oh my god. Okay,
I love this game already. Slimes are key to use. Shoot slimes through a coral barrier,
a corral barrier, not coral. Coral. Okay, okay. Are you ready to be imprisoned for life but in
exchange you get unlimited milk? There they go. Oh my god, three little reflings jumping in the pen.
One fell out and bumped his head and you go. Okay, that's cute. I'll allow it.
Shit slimes. No, damn party. They give us ink apparently. So I just go exploring.
Okay, let us analyze this game content. Why is of course some sort of sleep chamber? Oh,
it's got takeaway. It's got catch up on system offline. Right. Okay, we need to restore the power.
I hope I'm not supposed to be doing anything. New shifting colors like a dream fading just as
quickly. Oh yeah. And you come. Ha ha, got you. Oh my god, they're coming. Oh, there's cat. Oh my
god, wait, we can farm farm. New to vac pack. It's a rancher's best friend, carrots. Oh my god,
everyone get in. Do I need to like charge this? Whoa. Okay, this is come. Right, good boy. Who's
that good boy? You're coming on the farm. The milking farm never in. There's sheeby slime.
Hello. Hi. What do you do? Oh my god, it's literally called cotton slime. Oh my god, we have
sheeby. We have reflames, right? We just need Emmy, Azura, everyone else. Oh my god, this is
amazing. And you come. Okay, suck them all up. They've all come in. Hi, Johnny. Do not say the
slimes are pooping. Don't be a doodly. Poggle fruit. Oh my god, so that's so Poggish champus.
Right, so then go back and then whoa. Oh my god, this game is lagging low. Why?
Maybe that's what they meant when they were like, I, the game's early access.
The Puggers. Exactly. That's a secret path. Okay, not bad though. I do apologize for
broken my voices. I didn't make a cup of tea. I made one an hour ago when I woke up. I do apologize
for the lack of nothing anywhere. Guess who didn't eat anything yesterday and took medication to
sleep and then passed the book out. Okay, right, what? Food like fruits, veggies or chicken are
used to feed. Try shooting a bit of food. Yeah, it's hungry. Look, I'm supplying mommy's feed in here.
Whoa. How do I take this? Oh, I can walk in, but they can't come out. That's exactly how it should
be. We lost one. Wait, did I kill one? Feed yourself. Yeah, I'll do it after soon. Like, I feel fine.
That's something so surprising. I need to suck these. You acquire? No, not you, darling. No, no, I need
to, I just need the thingy, my bobbers. Stop. I don't know what the slime is. Right, there we go.
Pause the game again. No, I'm fine. I'm fine. Mommy shot a carrot to my noggin. Well, it was better
than me firing it elsewhere. Hey, how did you get there? Oh, my inventories feel right. Okay,
that's fine. That's fine. Right, what's this deal? The plot market, any plotters, the plot market
gives you new bucks for your hot end plots. Shoot a plotter into the plot market and earn yourself
some cash. Right, okay. Ah, I see. Okay, and now what? That about covers the basic. Now it's time
to get out there and explore. No matter where your adventure takes, always keep curiosity and kindness
in your heart. Wait, why is this game so wholesome? What the heck? How did I get on your pen? I have
bunnies on my inventory. Oh, it's down here. Hello. Why does it look like a horror game? What? Is this
my evil lab where like, I fucking take you down into the basement to like, milk you endlessly?
Like I have seven fucking rods in here. Honestly, I could see myself doing that.
Press F to activate. What are you? Oh, I can upgrade my backpack and stuff. What is this?
Cotton plot? What is it? Resource harvester as a resonator mechanism that shakes those science
resources from not... I don't know what that is. Sync with your body thingy. Put your heart rate up,
cotton. That one's pink. A heart module. Jetpack. I can fly. Tank booster. Improved nano storage
tech that allows your tank to hold 30 units of whatever it can say. So how do I get a new tank?
Oh, we're learning. We're learning. That's what happens when you play a game for the first time.
You have to learn everything. What's that? Okay.
It's making noise. Let's not go jumping off the map just yet. You can send us anytime.
I'm getting news. These are changing. Your interests are changing because of me.
But yes, the good news is I have never recorded the audio of all the shorts. I now need to pilot
my mech to synchronize with the footage. And then that's pretty much all my pre-made shorts.
And then I'll go back to working on the girl. Sheebie's waiting on an ASMR script.
Um, I might do a few membership hi-to-fag streams pop-up ones just to write you.
You think you can just escape? How dare you get in there? You're going to the milking farm. Press F to activate.
Slime agitation. An air net is a force fire that covers the top of the cage. It can take a few hits
before. How strange, right? So if I go here, happy nothing beats the taste of growing stuff.
Akute raises chickens. We can have chickens for fun. You never told me that. Oh, thank you for the tip.
And before anyone's like, you've not got your collar on. What are you here, huh?
What are you here? You make a new pen using fun. Akute. So how do I do it?
Right, buy it. Are you sure you want to purchase? Yeah. And put the bunnies in it?
Are they going to come flying out? Do I need to put like a barrier thing on top?
Oh, shit.
Yeah. I still got one, Mary's still got one, and now it's my turn. Wait, do you guys not like the fruit?
You don't like my offerings to you? No, no, no. Don't come back in me. Stop. Right. Stay here.
Wait, do you like it then? Okay, they like it.
Right. And then if they like it, but the cot, she be only like carrot. Surprise, surprise.
I'm trying to very gently pick up around bunnies like carrot ones. I'm lint. Oh, is this our house?
Can we go inside? Oh.
I've never been more disappointed in my looks. Right, okay, let's pop these away.
Right. What is that? It seems like we can unlock two more slimes, the gray and the blue. Let's go
find a gray and a blue slime. Can I have a thing that lets me? I said there is a farm plot. I think
we're going to have to do that. Yeah, garden by, yes. Now what? Shoot a fruit or veggie into it
to begin growing more of that type. Shit, I just got rid of them all. Right.
I hurt. Oh my God, we have a chicken. That was really lucky that it came over to me. Right,
we're going to keep the chicken on the inventory. Right, give me these carrots. Right, okay, we'll
go start growing carrots. We have a chicken, gray, matter, turning blue. Feed it to the slime. Feed
the chicken to the slime? No, we're going to have a chicken farm. Don't be so stinky. Right, funk.
Oh my gosh. Wait, I like this game. I thought it was going to be residential.
If this game is anything like the first part, this is going to be Mama Dream Incarnate,
being an architect, making money from it, upgrading the farm for even better architecting,
endless loop. Literally, I'm enjoying this. Like, I thought this was going to be like a
kind of game. No, this is cute as anything. I love it. Oh, sorry. Go eat some carrots.
Oh, two of them responded to that.
Right, and then pick up the gems, and then we'll get more water, more water, more money,
and then we'll make the chicken cap, and we're already on our way.
Well, we're never getting a good thing. I like it here, honestly. Right, I'll let the carrots
grow. We're going to go see what we can do. Maybe we can grab another slime. This is
out of order as well, but Wi-Fi system offline. Oh my god. I honestly thought this game was just
like a little two-minute resident, two-minute two-hour resident sleeper. I can...
A phosphorous slime. Oh my god. No, no, no. Give me the carrots because I need to feed the rabbit.
Right, I don't need any more pink slime. We've got enough pinkie.
We've got sheevee slimes coming out of nowhere. I want the nighttime ones. I'm here for the
nighttime gems. I need to, like, get in. Right, give me them.
What are you? Hello? Oh no, are you not well? Accessing GG Log. Well, here we go again. I'm
sending the drones out to all their original scouting locations. Once I confirm the coordinates,
our conditions are the same. I'll get to work this place. I still remember being in awe of the
rainbow field. It felt like being in a beautiful dream and I guess in a way it was because it
ended much too soon. Oh dear. Can I fix him? No, I can't. I can't fix him. I love that noise.
Okay, I don't need these guys. Come here. Come in. Stop it. Did he just ink on me? Are you
inking on me again right now? I need 20 years and then I'll put you some on your captive.
What's up ahead?
Oh, there's, like, so many. I love it. I can fix him, honestly.
Okay, I don't have enough inventory space. I can do carrot. Give me your carrots. Oh,
they're not growing yet. Oh, what are you? Hello? Press F to activate.
Uh, wait, it goes like, okay, this and this. That's how big it is, right? Wait,
why is it three out of three? Oh, wow. Oh, wow. I've been going one direction. There's
literally three more ways I can go. Hmm. Seems to be something important back here as well.
No, we would never. Another chicken. Okay, you have egg? No. Oh, the rooster is considered
different from a hen. Hmm. Oh, yeah. Are you supposed, oh, my, oh, my Largo. Largo slimes
are large slime hybrids formed when a slime eats a floor unlike them. Back to keep them on your
nozzle and shoot them to send them flying. What? I'm using it like a fucking bomb?
What the? That was just mean. This just looks like bullying.
You? I guess I can't get past this until something happens.
What are you? Ooh, water lettuce. We've not unlocked that yet.
Oh, my God. This game is so cute. Big bunny. Shoebie. I'm bouncing on Shoebie's head.
You can feed the big one. Uh-oh.
Do you want chicken? You don't want chicken. I'm afraid I'm out of carrots already. Oh, dear.
You don't have enough carrots in the old tub.
Whoa. What is going on? It's like a feast.
Um, imagine. Uh, right. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Cotton. I want to keep. I don't want to
drop anything. Right. Get rid of that one. I'm going to take the blue one so it'll be more.
God, we're all nomin' on stuff. What are we nomin' on?
That's like a fucking feast over here. Is it like a feast every night on the island?
Everyone seems to be getting along rather well, which I'm really happy about.
Go back and make some space. Yes. I'll get rid of the Firefly one. Oh, we're finally
finally it's conveniently transport resources and ports to the refinery where you can
excessively for your slime science in the lab.
Does that mean send it back or is that I'm lost? I need to go what way?
A little bit more to the right.
Can you feed the poop to other slimes to get combo breakers?
Oh, tar. Tar slime. I'm off. That was like something.
I'm not watching that person die. This slime didn't do anything wrong.
That was so mean. There was a flybot. Oh, is that not the same one I spoke to earlier?
Whoopsie. That was so mean. Born 4K. Exactly.
New message. Do you have a new message waiting at the comm station? Oh, is the comm station back up?
Right. I need to...
How is there... How are you showing up? There's more chickens just chillin'. They're ready to be
sucked in. Sucks in. Sucks in. Yeah, for all the cutesy in this game, the car can be terrifying.
Maybe I should have turned them off, but... Right, I get a lot of money for them. 300.
I need to get a new plot. Are you escaping? Oh, oh, so, so, oh, mummy, mummy. I want you to do
this to me. Mummy, mummy, mummy. I want you to do this and that. Eh, why are you trying to escape then?
Why are you trying to escape? I never said you could. I could.
Keeping chickens in their place prevents the uprising.
Eh, what? What is going on? It wasn't me. Okay, right, and then we put you in.
Are you just gonna fly out? You guys do have the ability to fly, I think.
Yeah, literally what?
What? High walls. I don't have the money.
Are the chickens uprising? Are the carrots ready to harvest?
Okay, I can make some emergency money with the carrots and trying to put a freaking
tall thing on top. They need a sun protector. Are they dying? Oh my, I never even thought about that.
Right, hurry up. Hurry up and start shitting. Start inking. Do you understand me? Start inking
right now. That's right. That's right. I want to see all that ink, baby. I want to see it all.
I want to see all that ink. Wait, you come in here with me.
Nope. Right, and then go out.
What are you doing? Are you eating my fucking? Why are you so big? Are you eating stuff you
shouldn't be? Be honest. Right, you come in here. I need one of you's on hand. Right, I need to buy
a sun protector. Got it. Surely this will have enough money now. Right, sun protector. I have
300 bucks. I need a sun protector. Unless I just suck them all in.
Come. Oh my God, not one of them is left. Get in sick. You naughty nailies. Right, sun protector.
Hurry up before you all die because you've been silly, Billy. I'm hungry. Who makes two greens,
honestly? Is there all going to perish? Get inside my gun. At least you're safe inside there.
I've definitely lost a few. I've only got 14. I thought I had like 20. Right, press F to activate.
Ear net. Solar shield. I don't have enough.
Oh, 500 and then I get like something that automatically does it. Auto feeder as well.
Oh my God, that's so good. Right, solar shield is 400 bucks. Can I like speak the, you get it?
You better stop. Oh, you're like coming out with coins on your own though. Okay. I mean,
I'm not going to come for him. Hello, mom. Hello, refund. What a cute little game.
I just think it's not like identified as finished yet.
Right, you get in. Oh, no. Well, you've done it now. You've done it now. Yeah, we're here.
You're going to die to the sun because you couldn't help yourself. How is there so many
pigs? Stop. Stop being smart and gathering like in dragon quests where they like stack up on each
other. I see one of these. I'm going to try and get it. What do I need? 450? I'm going to say
that they're probably going to perish. Oh, I don't have enough. I need more carrots.
We cannot be stopped. Literally, you're bursting it. Look at you doing it again. You're stacking
on each other to get out. What do you mean I don't milk you enough to get you to stay around?
My nonsense is this. I'm just going for food. Right, there's no carrot there. That's fine.
I just need food. Food, food, food, food, food, food. Give me food. Give me food. Give me food.
For the reason why I need food. I need food. I need food. What are you? Whoa.
A cell heart. Used as a fabricator to upgrade the back hearts module. Okay. No, no, give me these.
Okay, I have carrot and I have two galorebs. Resource harvester upgrade required.
Well, I can grab more chains, I guess. No. Right. You might as well come with me.
What would be? Oh, jeez. There you go. What are these? A Q-Berry, delicious and sweet,
and they never roll off the table. I need food. Right, food first. I know those courts equal money,
but if I come back with, like, I'll load it right into the water, you know. I just need carrots,
really. If I get the bunnies full, they can combine. They're getting, reeflands are getting stronger
than me. They're better than me. They're faster than me. It's not looking good. I don't know if I
should put the Q-Berry down. Where? I'm struggling with the fine food. Right, where they're slain,
there's food, so I've got to get these. Should I just go on a run where I pick up three diamonds
that come off of them? Right, I'm heading back to the conservatory with my two carrots. Yeah,
that's gonna really tip me over there. I guess a Q-Berry is what they're gonna... Right, two
of you eat that. Do you eat Q-Berry? No! Who eats Q-Berry, then? Nope, nope, take that out. Right,
give me that. Do they make... Do they ever make the courts on their own?
Can I throw up? I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry to do this. I genuinely am so sorry. Get the
fuck out of here. Was that what I was supposed to do? I don't know what I was supposed to do.
I didn't know what I was supposed to do. I'm like, get out of here. You're eating my
purr babies. Oh, literally, my purr babies didn't deserve that. Okay, 450. Can I sell slime?
Like actual slimes? Okay, not to be con... Can I sell them? No, okay, you can't sell them.
But they do seem to poop on their own. Stop coming out of your pen! How is there a bunny in your pen?
Sheeby, the harlots, the reeflings... What's going on? Right, I've got four, three, nine. What was I
doing with that? The solar one, so I can do the... So I can keep these guys alive, right? Solar
shield. Bye, thank you, yes. A solar shield will encase the corral in a dim shade, protecting
slimes that are sensitive to light. Okay, but are they gonna go flying out? It's my question.
We'll ensure that even the bounciest of slimes will have difficulty escaping. An air net is a
force bar that covers the top of it. It can take a few hits before needing to recharge. Air net or high
wall. Okay, this is getting rather intricate. I take back all my compliments about this game.
Right, how much is a farm? $2.50, that's very much like... Or how much is a chicken farm? We need,
obviously, we need our chicken farm. Okay, it's $2.50, that's not that bad. Air net is also tar protection.
Have you guys played this game before then? You're real gamers who actually play video games,
not like me. Not like me, he does it for male attention. Why aren't you growing? I think I might
need to drop the cubaries in favor of something else. I want to keep the chickens. They seem decent.
Okay, I see these little diamonds, we're just gonna grab them.
Do they like put them out naturally? Can you guys keep doing it? Right, did that activate you or not?
Sending the original drone out to the... Right, okay, no, we did interact with that one. Upgrade
for the resource, that's the water one, which we don't have yet. Mom, we have different diets,
only the pink leaflings are omnivores. Okay, okay, okay. I'm just gonna get rid of that.
I'd rather pick up little pieces now. If you guys are pooping out little pieces, I'm gonna pick them up.
You're inking everywhere, good. I wonder if I get rid of the... No, don't eat it. No, you stinker,
I was selling these pieces. Oh wait, I don't... Right, you know what? There's fucking chickens
everywhere, just do what you want. Do what you want chickens, you win. I'm picking up all these like
monies because I'm needing to upgrade the farm. The farm needs a big upgrade, but I keep messing
it off, but there's not enough. Give me it. Give me all these little pieces. I just want to be able
to empty my inventory of the solar one. Okay, they're pooping, they're pooping. I'm getting them,
I'm getting them, I'm trying to listen out to win the next one poops. I'm like, come on, come on,
give me that, the court. Okay, we'll move on to the next area. Okay, those are the chicken. Are you
eating the chicken? What are you doing? You are, good boy. Give me. No, not you though. Keep eating
the chickens, go on a big chicken feast. Refinery links, you keep saying that, but I don't know what
it does. Oh, that doesn't work. You keep saying that, but I don't know what it means. I saw that up there.
Hey, I saw that, you pervert.
Oh my God, it's a tabby. They must eat chicken. Oh my God, they must eat chicken.
Oh, they're so cute. Oh my God. Give me all 20. I'll take 20 of them right now.
No questions asked. That is so cute. Right, I'm off. I'm putting them in.
They're so, so cute. Oh, those are nickel ones. I wonder if they're worth any more. Press F to
activate. Okay, we have more of the map unlocked. Jesus. Right, what we do have to go to get back.
Straight ahead, roughly. Oh, he's eating. What are you eating? You never warned me how cute
this game was. I can't believe it. There's a cave in here. Did we go exploring? Hello, Mr. Cave.
Oh, it's not much of a cave. It's like a bypass. Hello. Do you have things I can sell? You do.
Thank you. This will greatly help with my investment of the nickel. Why is it so cool?
I go around the corner. I see a water thing. I see the world's smallest fucking chicken.
Is that a chick? It must be a chick. There's no way that's supposed to be a chicken.
Nearly. I don't even believe it.
Warning video gave me contained unreasonable amount of cuteness. It is, and it does.
Oh my god, I can like harvest all their poopies. Right, it makes it a lot easier that I can like
make money without having to make money on inside the farm. Like, they're just pooping,
pooping up. They're pooping up a storm right now. Am I going the right way?
Kind of. I'd like to break it for the most part. No, I'm away.
No, sorry. No, no, no, no, no, no. I want these. Don't throw them away. I want those guys.
You're upsetting me, video game. Today I kidnapped 20 reflux. Oh, hello. What are you?
Diet fruit. Oh, they're not going to move out of the way until I feed them. Snorlax style, like Pokemon.
The Snorlax is in your way yet again. Are you kidding me right now?
I had a map. It is just for you. I knew you would love this game.
It's so cute. It's like a very relaxing game. I'm not sure if we're going to like finish the
campaign mode or anything like that. Oh, I forgot I had a message. I completely patched it. Sorry.
There, there's a bit of a Scottish slang. Fuck NL, you guys are escaping everywhere.
A message. System offline. A message? System back online.
Victor. Hello. Hello, Beatrix. Do you read, mate? Testing, testing. Perhaps you are lost at sea.
Taken away, but like with serious boat. Never to be. Oh, no. Just forgot to turn your display on.
Nice to see your face again, Beatrix. I missed you greatly. My dear friend.
Well, I'm quite excited for you to partake in a new adventure. I already have data that might
complicate this. Fair enough. Thank you, Crazy Jessie for the tip and Frostino for the tip as well.
Sorry, I'm being really bad at saying your names. Last night, I received a message from some sort of
artificial intelligence program. It's written in code, but not one I recognize. I'm in the process
of analyzing it, but I am certain that this message was sent from where you are now. The mysterious
rainbow island. So, recap. A mysterious boat takes you to a mysterious island and I receive
a mysterious code from a mysterious island. It all seems quite curious. Not mysterious?
Well, I've got work to do and you'd best get exploring. Oh, I almost forgot. Take this home
portal. It should make the early stages of your journey easier. Blueprint no phone for a fabric
here. Yellow return home portal. Take care, Beatrix. We'll be in touch. Oh my. Okay. Right. Let's
put all this money away. Money, money, money. Unfortunately, my inventory is very motherfucking
full right now and I'm a bit at the mercy of I don't know what it takes to upgrade it. I'm going
under the lab to see what it takes to upgrade. I assume the Neckos are just going to go flying out.
Although I was saying that I can put the roof on top now. Hold on. Air net. It takes a beating
but it'll come back. I mean, I swear if they all escape then I'm not going to be very pleased to
be honest. Oh for fuck's sake. So what? They're going to break it instantly and I'll go flying out.
So what? I'm supposed to do high walls with them as well. 260. I've no got 260 quid. No, I've no.
And there's new veggies. So what was that all about? Making me need to turn that down.
Right, fuck it. We'll go this way. We're not being this way.
You're gonna have to reinstall it. It is a very chill casual game. Press F to activate the den.
The dark damp mushroom covered expansion of the conservatory is a refuge
from the sun for slings and ranchers alike. Bye. What in the capitalism is going on here?
That would do me. Let's go to the front of the island then. Let me guess.
Paywall. You know what? And what? The third time Lucky's also a paywall? No, it can't be
because I threw a slime off the map. A rude one. Hello. Okay, there's a chickadee. You're done.
You're done getting absolutely done, Zo. Right, if these slime ones eat in hen, eat and eat.
Oh, no, I don't want to. No. You must be able to sell slimes as well for monetary value, but hello.
Name books. Name books. Name books. Right, I'm going under and I'm going to see.
Are you dead yet or do you still alive? No, you're surprisingly still alive.
We'll keep it that way. Where's the underground path? To the left. Only the poop. Okay.
You can sell their poop, but you cannot sell their food in.
You got some bunnies in with your pink. I know, I'm just letting them.
Right, Fabricated Legit Crafter. Yes, I don't have anything though.
No, that doesn't make sense. I don't have anything. Warp tech couldn't be less of a
shape. Decorations can be less of a shape. I want upgrades. Don't need more health.
What does that mean? A jet pack of tank goes to improve nano storage
sellers in the back of the whole third unit, so wherever you can suck up. But what about like more?
That's an extra general purpose tank. Right, but I don't have anything.
Mm-hmm. That's right. Mommy's a bit too dumb to understand what the fuck the game wants from her right now.
The refinery. Yay. What is this? What do you do? In order to fabricate gadgets, you'll need to shoot
some resources into the refinery, but remember, and then you've already got rid of the thing,
but remember what? Come back. No. Come back, bruv. I'm ready to strip off and just take the pictures
and put it on my alt footer right now because I don't know what I'm doing. I feel embarrassed.
I don't know what I'm doing. What do you mean? Play the game for the first time? At least the
gameplay. That's kind of mildly bad and not optimized. I'm going to say I'm not going to make it. Right,
okay. We need more money. And to obtain money, we must feed. We must go into our architect
poll. And to be honest, the first one also kind of threw a ton of stuff at you at once.
I just need money. Right. I'm going to get carrots. Okay. It looks like all the field resources
have spawned back in. So let us pray that we can make enough money to do what we need to do.
Copium. I'm grinding for the poop. No, the ink! Don't call it poopy!
I feed you food and you ink. I'm an architect. I don't care. You can make fun of it.
Make all the fun you want about it. Who's the one that gets off to a takeaway?
You need to like stick your leg in a bear trap just to fucking ink. Me? A bit of takeaway.
Wait, why aren't you going in that one? No, don't. No, I don't want that.
Yeah. You're not shaming me this time.
What was that noise? Your shirt.
Right. That's a lot of... I think they're just eating the absolute living daylight.
Everything. Right. Let's head back. Mummy. Yeah. You think I added those at most for no reason?
Let me feed you. Okay. Sounded like Link's here. Honestly. I heard that too. I was like...
Right. I have 20 carrots. Surely that's like 500 bucks and then we can do the
Neckle Tank at least. Even though the Slimes are just doing whatever the fuck they want.
Right. For the well-behaved rabbits, guess what? They get food. No, no, no, no. You wanted to jump
out your re-cage so much. The well-behaved ones get in there. They get fed. No, no. You all wanted
to jump out. Now you have to face the actions of your consequences. Hold on a minute. I said that
the wrong way around. But you know what I meant. You know what I meant. You know what I meant.
No, no, no, no, no. You're not allowed to ask me for forgiveness. No, no. It was too late.
I had a burger today. Good. Was it greasy? Was it full of fat? Sugar? All the bad stuff?
Okay. 450. Surely that's enough for a fucking Neckle Pen. Right. A new pen. Put the Neckles in it. Yes.
Neckles. In you go. Do not jump out. I do not have the money for you to jump out. Do you understand?
To comprehende. Oui. Right. And then chickens are next. Right. Chickens are next. Chickens are next.
Chickens are next. We will harvest the chickens and put them in a wee pen.
Okay. And then we're going to pick up these. We need 250.
Okay. Is that everyone inked? Is everyone inked up? Right. Everyone inked up. Everyone's empty and happy.
Did Anna just put all these in one go? Right. Fucking how did you get out? How are you already
there? I was literally freaking two seconds ago. I'll put you in. Right. Chicken.
Why do you look so cute though?
Why do you look so cute? Right. I'm going to put the chicken next to the cat. Okay.
And the reason for that is they'll see the prey is right there. Okay. And then we're
hashtag winning. Right. Now we need... Okay. Surprisingly, this hasn't grown yet. I think
we're going to need a few more plots of food because it's taken so long to grow.
Chat, we need to explain the market to Mummy. There's a market. I played and beat the first one.
How's the sequel? It's going... I mean, it's all right. I'm just not very smart. I'm just going
to keep adventuring further this time. Hello little flies. The market is where you sell the plot.
Yeah. The big machine that I throw them into. No, these are my carrots. I need them for my...
Oh, sorry. You can't like open the map and keep going. I think it was telling me going through.
Nope. It was not telling me go this way. Oh, that was me trying to take a shortcut that failed.
You need to understand where you can and cannot sell the plot. Soon. Soon.
It is my first playthrough. So if you're getting frustrated, guess what? I will make it up to you
very shortly. Hello. Press S to activate. I have already activated that. Uh, map. Take a little to
the right and then just keep pressing W. Got it. Oh, chicken. I need you to come with me.
Or not, I guess. No, stop asking me about the freaking refinery. I was so in over my head
when I first started here. I remember hauling jelly stones back to the conservatory by hand
because I was so excited. Breathless and sweating. I was going about everything all wrong, but I was
happy. There's a lot of time now. So I need to... these refineries, like, if I'm going to be efficient
this time, I'm going to do it right. Okay. Oh, the bumblebees take it away. Right. Okay, we're going
to the cavern. And then we'll see what's up ahead. No, baby. Jump, jump, jump, jump.
Okay. Water, water upgrade I don't have. Chicken, you're coming with me. Chicken,
you're coming with me. Chicken, you're coming with me because I've got a chicken pen for you.
Can chickens die?
Wait, what? Isn't there not more? There is more. I need to go up. Up and along. Right, up and along,
up and along, up and along, up and along. Yes, chickens get old and will pass away.
That's not very nice. Wait, is this not on a continuation?
Ain't a lie. How'd I get up there?
Is there a pathway or am I just making stuff up? It's very plausible.
That I could be just making stuff up. Oh, this is a dead end.
Oh, okay. Oh, it's a jetpack jump. No, it means to progress. I already have to do upgrades.
Oh, whoa, it's me. Whoa, it's me. Wait, why aren't you coming?
God, my gun needs an upgrade already? I suck. The cube berries?
Have I been here? Kind of.
More chickens, I'll take them. A stone hen? I've only just unlocked enough. No, I don't want,
I want the gems. No, the gems. They must eat these cube berries. That's fine. I'll, I'll
love it. I'll love it. Stony hen. Oh, actually, stony hen. They're like, push their heads together,
like honk, honk. Someone's making noises. Someone's making noises. I don't know who it is,
it's one of my fucking minions. Hmm. Hmm, they're down here. Can you like, jump up on something
to get it? Nope. Right, right. I'm in a listen. Did we go there?
Right, we'll try and go here next and see what the Helio is like there.
And then we will unlock the secret. Oh, will someone please think about the secrets of the map?
Right, no. Take a right and then tickle that.
And then, yeah, right, do a U-turn. U-turn when? U-turn now? Right, if you say refinery link,
I'm off. They're so nasty. I wonder if I help them become good again. I could see myself doing that.
Are they chasing me? Right, they better not be. I'm out. I'm out. Yeah, that's right,
you put that relaxing classical music back on. I wish, so you press M to open up the map,
but when you press M, it doesn't close it again automatically. Is it like a tab? Like,
there's no map feature like that. Right, what was over there?
What is this? A little to the right?
Honestly, it's probably a lot more beneficial to pick up all this
than it is to have one random chain. Is this another backpack thing? No. Right, I made it.
We're at a new location. It only took me, oh, I swear to God, that looks like a backpack thing.
Press F to activate. Okay.
Okay, jump. It's a dead end cavern.
Oh, something came out of it. What car is? Interesting.
The towers are too evil for redemption. Oh, no. I like when, like, obviously in Viva Pinyata,
you have like evil Pinyatas, but they're not evil. They just really want stuff.
And then when they get it, they become like nice little Pinyatas and they're so cute.
Like, I love a good redemption art. You know me. I'm all about the redemption.
That first. Right, so they can't break out, which is good.
Oh, sorry. Right, I'll give you these. And then I'll put these checking away over here
to taunt the neckos. I'll put the chicken here.
And then I don't know what I need to feed chickens. Maybe carrot? I mean, if I was a
chicken, I'd eat carrot. Oh, it's 38 for the necko poop. Do you mind? Can you stop?
How are you getting out? You're not coming out when I'm here?
Oh, look at them. They're all interested in the chicken.
Wait, can you jump in and hurt them?
You just need a external food. Oh, how is there so many of you out?
You guys are so big over here.
I guess that's what I'm supposed to do to the end. Stop eating the fucking stop.
There's so many big ones. I don't, I don't need your big. I need you to farm.
This game isn't, isn't, isn't relaxed at all. I like, please, I just need more money.
It's making me turn into, no, don't eat the carrots. Those are for me.
Danny put a wall around the farm.
A sprinkler system, a scare slime, a scare, to deter wandering slimes away.
No way. I need to put a scarecrow down. Stop eating. No.
You're naughty. You're naughty. You shouldn't do that.
I'm completely messing this up. Hi, how are you doing?
I'm hungry. Stress and exploitation.
Literally, what role am I playing this fucking, how are you here? Go out of the pen.
I have no basic rabbits left to feed fucking corn. This isn't corn, this is carrot.
I literally, is that cat? No. You're the problem. Get out of here.
Please, please stop turning my carrot slimes into the freaking, wait, out and out. Get out of my
freaking suction. Stop it. Right. I suck at this game. It's cute though, but I suck at it.
Right, give me the carrot. Oh, he's eating him.
Oh my gosh, this is going terribly. This couldn't have gone any worse if I just
had planned it to. Can you guys stay in your pen and then can you get the fuck out of the pen?
Why are the big ones so interested in the wee ones? Go away. You've already transformed.
It's not clicking. No, out. Out. I need money. I need money to do it. Stop. Stop. Stop it.
Is they're all in her breeding?
You don't suck at this. Rain, muddy, dreary, cozy, wonderful? What?
Whether light drizzle downpour rain can make any corner of the, a little more dramatic,
but rain can also keep tar at bay. Naturally, water, wild fruit and veg and crops and delight
puddles. Right, we're going to take the carrots to the rabbit one that was stuck in the ground.
I'm going to just take the L on this. Where was the carrot one here? We're going to try and get
whatever's behind him. Copey, I'm surely six more. Carrots will be fine, right? Right? Give me the carrots.
New carrots to the warty harvest with them. Right, there's a cute one nearby in a cavern
here, but I don't know. Oh, nope, not grown yet.
Little to the left, a little to the left.
I definitely, I think this is more of a game you play, like, silently to yourself. For a stream game,
I am not entertaining enough to make this, like, si-hi-egg thing so fun.
I'm not that kind of streamer, okay? Right, a little, I've gone too far now.
And here, hello? Are you up here, Mr. Rabbit? Okay, here you are.
Oh, hold on, let me grab these just before someone else's.
Abing, aboom, abing, aboom, aboom, aboom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Twenty wasn't enough?
Are you serious?
Oh, sorry, I thought that was a carrot. Wait, did I not have a carrot?
Did you eat that fucking carrot? No, I need this one carrot, fuck off.
I need this one carrot. That makes twenty, right?
Huh?
It doesn't explode? Does it just respawn more rabbits? Is that all it does?
It just respawns more?
Uh, he's about to bust just a few more carrots. Shit.
Uh, carrots, carrots, carrots, carrots.
Bust, busting, he's about to bust.
Or you, you're a carrot? He's bustin'.
Are you about to bust? Me every stream.
Uh, one?
How much do you require? Oh, I'm off to find more carrot, then.
At least I can sell all the rabbit little thingamabobbers.
Right, if you tell me about the refinery link one more freaking time,
uh, I'm gonna shit on your motherfucking lawn.
Right, there's a tar, but there's carrots here, so.
Sorry, priorities, priorities, I need carrots. Sorry, I really focus on getting more carrots
right now. I am not going back to that thing. I, I, it needs to pop, okay? It needs to pop.
I need carrot. I need carrot. Yes, I do. I need carrot. How about you?
Eminent death, keep it out. Right, you can come with me.
I can't jet pack. I need jet pack, so.
Leaving them to their fate. Did they just, did they go to slime heaven?
I'm pretty sure that's like way more expensive than, uh, the pink one.
Where, I think that's all the carrot on the map I can obtain right now.
So, unless, unless, unless, unless.
No, stop eating, stop eating, these are mine, these are mine.
I'm taking away the natural resources to benefit my own desires.
Give me them natural resources.
Give me the resources. Right, now to find the rabbit again. Where is it?
He's a little to the right. Okay, up the hill to the right, up the hill to the right, up the hill to the right.
Up the hill. Surely.
Bon appetit. Then what's there?
A, a mineral. Oh, that's how you even, no, wait, what?
Is there something special at the end of this? There better be something special.
What did you press S to activate?
Excuse me?
Ah, what the fuck? All right, let's go investigate that bad boy.
Let's go investigate that.
Pregnant, Pregnanto.
I like how you take no full damage.
Look how big they are because they ate all of the bunny's poop.
What way was it? Is it this way?
Ah, it is this way. Let's go.
Right, wait, what? Is this not what I was looking at? Was I not looking at this?
Oh, wait, what did I just do? This? There's something. Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
All right, all right, all right, desolate, desolate. I understand. I'm a bit confuzzled,
but I did unlock something. Right, just go dead ahead if you can.
I'm a bit confuzzled, but I've got the spirit. That's the main thing.
I believe I mean quest appear, but I'm not sure the same was a big enough.
This, right? Okay, okay, hold on, something's happening.
Sorry, I literally went right up to it and then back away.
Uh-huh.
Oh, and where are we?
Okay, I wish I would have told me that. I would have emptied my inventory first,
but you know what, I'll take it.
Let's check it out.
Okay, nothing particularly the ordinary.
Okay, yes, we'll just keep exploring.
Is there lore to the island?
This looks very lore-esque. Oh, there's new ones. Hello, where are you?
A roco slime. I guess the only rock chicken.
Yeah, yeah, I bet they do.
Okay, let's grab the roco slime.
You get slimes everywhere, honestly.
Ow, you hurt me.
Hmm, analyzing, analyzing.
Surely there's more to go, or we already like at the end,
it's like the game's like no further.
Hi.
Keep out death, but like actually keep out death or just Teehee keep out death.
Like video game Teehee.
Oh, they're pissed.
Okay, right, you win. I'm not going in.
No, don't, no, AI get off of me. I'm no longer in the area.
AI get off of me. Am I good?
Oh, oh yeah, Teehee.
I could freaking pop you off the map in a heartbeat.
Wait, maybe I can just evade them.
Well, hello there gamers. Oh, we're gaming all right.
Oh, I can't suck them away from me.
Right, okay.
You're new. Oh my gosh, what are you?
Just give me a moment. Hold on real quick.
Just let me get rid of all of you.
I want to grab the new one.
Hello?
Honey?
Honey Slime?
You can come with me.
Come with me.
I'll take you a nice, nice, much nicer place in here.
Hello, Honey Slime.
Cute and honey.
Yeah.
Oh, Angler.
Is it attacking me?
Oh my gosh, it's like flashbang and hold on.
I don't want to get rid of the water cabbage
because I want to grow it.
Oh my gosh, there's so many new ones.
Right, we have enough to breed.
So pretty.
Let me get closer.
Look, in you come.
Oh, they're so pretty.
There's like big ones.
Okay, this should do me.
I'm going to head back with my newfound Slime.
Oh, there's like a hidden door here.
Right, hide ahead back that way.
The way, come the way you came.
Oh, hey, I finally caught a stream.
Hi, sorry.
I've not been doing longer streams
because I'm trying to do some behind the scenes work.
The super secret event is getting wrapped up
very shortly.
So you'll be able to...
I can finally talk about it.
And my body has been failing me,
making me sleep for 13 hours.
And I'm like, well, like, guy, use me.
I'm not going to want to be sleeping for 13 hours.
Do you know how much work I could have got done?
Right, and we'll go back to the teleport,
which that's off the hill.
Oh, that rock is so cute.
Oh, am I to get the...
Am I to get him to come attack me
and like, throw Dan to this rock?
Oh, sorry.
Oh, no, that's a nice one.
Sorry.
Oh, there's honey.
I must be able to harvest honey for these.
Are you two in?
Get in here.
No, he is evil.
Is he?
Are you a mean one?
Are you mean?
Oh, am I going crazy and they're nice and subdued now?
Do that is something to subduem?
Oh, it must have been a rock
and a good one coming together
and not the mean ones.
Okay, that's not the answer.
Sorry.
I thought it was the answer, but it wasn't.
Good sleep means more productivity.
I would...
I think so.
I genuinely think so.
I've swapped the membership stream to a script writing one
because it's been four months now
and I have still yet to send some girls their script.
And I'm like, I'm actually getting a bit embarrassed about it now.
Like, it's all fine being like,
Australian stream every day.
It's like, that's understandable.
Have a nice day.
I'm getting embarrassed, okay?
And I'm the one wearing a dog collar right now.
And I'm getting embarrassed.
I don't get embarrassed by that,
but I get embarrassed if I'm making someone wait,
especially when they agree to give me their time.
I just feel like, ooh.
You know, like, ooh.
Purposyden.
No, so Posyden did get her script.
It's Maeve who hasn't had her script yet.
There's one girl, Umi.
I'm like, 99% sure I finished the script.
But I might go on another account.
I might need to send it over before I start up the membership stream.
But like, there's another girl that's friends with Sheebie
that I initiated a conversation with
and then forgot to do the old,
oh, hey, I'm messaging you for a collab.
I'm not just randomly asking you how you're doing
because I don't want to waste your time.
I completely forgot to do the part where, hey, let's not,
don't let me, like, let's not waste your time.
I value your time.
Stop fucking eating the carrots.
I swear.
Right.
I need to buy this.
Yes.
And because I want to plant this,
because that seems to be so rare that I, like, never have it.
Do you guys eat that?
You don't.
What do you eat?
I don't know what you eat.
Well, if I'm growing up, I don't actually need it.
And then am I going to have enough for another corral?
I'm not because that would have been too easy.
Stop.
Stop spawn camping the carrots.
I see what you're doing.
You guys are not even tripping anything for me.
Can you kill one of these?
Neco.
Can you go kill the chickens so I can
add to car?
Your personal promo link is now online.
Stop by for the best deals in the galaxy.
I don't have the mutt.
God, they're so patient.
You ate my chicken.
Are you serious?
Holy shit.
Look how many more I've discovered
because of the rock slime.
Wait.
The money changes every day.
Honey slime is 36.
Angler fish slime is 63.
Huh.
Yummy chicken.
No, I never said eat that.
Stop.
No, you already know what's about to happen,
accept your fate.
Accept your fate.
Get out of here.
Where's the other one?
Huh?
Did you just beat it up?
Not the Neco slime.
Did the Neco slime just protect everyone?
Did he just help everyone?
Pronto match.
Poli Star provisions is online on the video straight.
Poli Star provisions has everything a rancher could ever need and mower.
Check back for regularly.
Cuckoo Corner is online.
Cuckoo Corner has crazy deals on you and exclusive items.
Wee-haw.
What's Cuckoo Corner?
Hatching new deals when the clock strikes midnight.
A fucking cannon?
Oh.
Oh, if you're struggling, it just like straight up.
And I just straight up.
Thanks.
No, I'll stick here.
These are just stickers?
I thought it was going to be like, do you need to buy fruit here?
Buy it.
I didn't expect that.
Wait, what?
Are you serious?
Don't I have one of these fuckers around?
They finally broke out.
It only took them how long?
What do you even eat?
Just stay in there.
Oh my God.
Who's fucking being chill into this game because it's moving?
So now I have limited inventory.
I need to try and feed my rabbits.
They aren't even in my fucking corral.
Give me, give me like a billion carrots right now.
Nope.
They're, I'm not just, I'm not just let them eat.
Just fucking take it.
You win.
What even are you?
You fucking just eat it.
Yeah.
That's what I thought.
Right.
I'm picking up the pink ones.
I'm selling the pink.
Jobby.
No, Inc.
The pink Inc.
Not jobby.
Everyone says jobby in the game.
I'm just picking them all up and I must sell them.
I am rather hardcore.
Thank you.
More like hard in your core.
Right.
I'm losing a little bit, but that's okay.
Nice drawing.
Happy plan.
New tabby is a new exclusive slay.
Literally the tabby killed the enemy.
I'm like, is there any main to further?
Give me these so I can sell them.
If I can free up my inventory.
That's what's happening.
Could they not have given you five?
I feel like four is a little on the low side.
And by a little on the low side,
I'm like, what am I supposed to do with four inventory?
Everyone's jumping about.
Everyone's fucking morphed into these different kinds that I don't want.
They're fucking spawn camp.
Stop spawn camping the carrots.
Oh my gosh.
I don't have enough money to even buy a scarecrow.
Right.
Praying I have enough money for a new closure
so I can put something in the closure
and pray that it doesn't fucking escape.
Like all the other bloody things.
Oh.
Not, not getting here.
Do not start morphing.
I'm going to cry so hard.
I just heard it morph behind me.
I'm sure I can upgrade.
No.
Out.
Please.
I'm begging.
Get out of here.
No.
I kept the heat eaten.
Please keep eating.
Don't know why you're so.
As if I didn't milk is every day.
Like I'm sorry.
What's the problem?
Go and get away.
Oh you fucking little shit.
Your poop is not as worthy of that price tag.
That is why I'm trying to.
No.
Your poop isn't worth that much.
Please eat someone.
Please get out of here.
Please eat.
Why?
Eat.
Thank you.
Bro.
Can you rob?
Thanks for the tip.
No message though.
You know you can type in that little book.
Okay.
You feel that high strong?
I'm a high reason.
You don't have to but there's an option.
There boom.
The most un-relaxed fucking game I've ever played.
I'm getting annoyed.
I'm like everything's jumping out.
Everything's morphing together.
And yes I comprehend the game mechanic
is I'm supposed to put money in a scarecrow.
I do not have 425 coins for a scarecrow.
And I don't even know who eats blue cabbage.
Is that a rock slime?
Do you eat blue cabbage?
Who eats blue cabbage?
Hi.
No you can send that for free.
Don't give me money for messages.
Don't do it.
Right.
The rock slime clearly wasn't the answer.
Who eats fucking wet cabbage?
You eat wet cabbage?
Diet meat.
Right.
Well we're not having you out then.
What is your diet fruit?
Right.
I'm not gonna make it.
Wait I'm already out of plots?
Huh?
Can I not upgrade for more plots?
Rabbits and rock slime will both eat veggies
that's a blue cabbage.
You can look it up.
It's in the compendium.
Oh what is it called?
It's comfy but it looks a bit more...
So did I get rid of the lower level slimes
in order to make way for the ones
that have stronger popes?
Cause I mean...
Like we can shove the anglers in here.
Oh oh oh!
Is that what I'm supposed to do?
Want to put him in there to be destroyed?
No.
What?
A min max then?
I thought it was gonna be one of those
games that look cute but it's actually scary.
It's frustrating that's what it is.
It's absolutely awful.
Right so...
Because I know on the other gear that I'm supposed to...
So then what?
Just take out all of these guys?
And then put the rock?
You can't have like infinite form?
A rock slime's a veggie.
Right so then we'll put the veggies for him.
Right?
I'm too like you for this.
I actually am.
I thought you could have like all of them alive at once.
I thought that would have been nice.
Okay they'd definitely be eating that though.
Okay and the problem is...
Yeah we instantly get fucking invaded!
Are you f-
How?
I literally just watched it change before my-
Get the fuck out of here.
Right so I'm supposed to put a thing on the roof.
What?
Are rock slimes evil?
Get out of here.
Oh my gosh!
Out!
Are rock slimes fucking evil?
Huh?
They can evilly fight each other.
What?
How did that go so terribly wrong?
Who are you fighting each other?
When you mix three slimes they turn evil?
I only got 24 for that.
Right we're fucking needing to put a fucking roof on there.
Or an ear net.
And I literally am missing the price of one.
Can you please eat that?
Someone is twerking on my head right now.
Can you please eat this?
Like I am begging you to eat that.
I need literally four coins to put a roof on this one.
Or at least put the ceiling off a bit.
Oh!
I'm begging.
We are gonna have so many evil ones.
High walls, bye!
Don't ever fucking come out again.
Get the fuck out.
Unless you are a cute little blue slime.
Stay mother fucking in here.
How are the-
I have no anglers.
They're all gone.
This farm is a mess.
This- this isn't even a farm.
This is just chaos.
These are rolling about hurting everyone.
Fuck off!
If you're gonna become an evil one at least fucking do it in the ocean.
Jesus.
I don't know what to do.
I don't have any money.
I don't have the stonk.
Please don't shoot them randomly.
They don't despawn.
Mummy, clear your base.
We have guests coming over.
Oh, you stream sniping to help me.
Thank god.
All my chickens are dead.
All my nails are pouncing on me.
I don't know why.
Are they just wanting a pet?
Well, here's your two buddies that were missing earlier.
All my chickens are dead.
All the tricks are dead.
I give up.
I submit I've been defeated yet again by a child to get-
Go fucking the pen!
I don't have money to make the walls higher.
I don't have money to unlock like the next few areas either.
Broken by a child then.
They're hungry and their piss cover tummy's empty.
I don't understand how you're supposed to-
You're only supposed to like farm a few at a time though?
Because I don't have any more plots to put food on.
Are they actually angry at me?
We'll be angry as well.
I think we might have been defeated by this game.
I'm afraid I cannot wholeheartedly recommend it.
Maybe it's just because if for stream game this really isn't that valuable.
Well, no.
Sorry.
Let me re-
Let me be clear.
As if yous are chilling in my lap!
What is this?
Is that Kitsune?
Playtime gets the wiggles out.
Are you wanting to play?
Is that what it is?
I still have so many morphins left.
Yeah, you aren't supposed to spend all your money at once.
I'm sorry because I don't agree with you.
I'm sorry but-
Hmm.
Why don't they just say what it is?
Not utilities, other one.
No, not that one, the other one, upgrades, yeah.
Ten, a radiant order, they even have that.
A pedicor.
What does it mean?
Someone came down for this.
Do you wanna read marshmallows for the next half an hour?
And I'll tell you about all my secret diabolical plans
Would you rather do that when we talk about my ace of microlapse there coming up
Sure
Can I stop playing this game, please? Yeah, I'm afraid it's not one for me
I wasn't on the cards. I'll use it for background music. I've got that though. Well, I'll keep it background music
aim
a
Aim
Sunny you need to force read me marshmallows like it's a chubby bunny challenge. Oh true and real. I remember that one viral
What was the other one? It was like a you put cinnamon in your mouth and you're supposed to like it's so dry
Like you're not supposed to do anything with it
Hold on
I'm gonna very quickly and get a can of cola and then we'll just read marshmallow as well blab away about all my plans
I get to leak
And
But yeah, sorry for the late start to the stream
You're going to see very quickly because I'm already gonna pass on to the editors because I don't need to edit that content
I have a hand some more video coming out where it's just my hands and my beautiful nails you hear their nails
I'm gonna very quickly get a
cola and
I
Thought I didn't turn it off and I've been wasting the battery in the bathroom the entire time
Ma thanks for the 10 gifts. I'll be one second
You
Right I've got cola and a bit of cheese. This was my first meal with my two biscuits yesterday because I forgot to eat
Whoopsies
Thank you again Ma for the 10 gifted membership and congrats to those who caught them with your face. Enjoy them all
There's more on the way soon TM soon soon TM
I'll need to see what the update on Icy embers and merches and rope shower
Affeguard he eat I went to bed and I was like I set my alarm for midnight
And I'll get up at midnight and do everything and then I woke up
At like half two I think and I was like, oh shit
But I still technically did what I needed to do
And I just need to sink my short. So if you didn't know when you record a short
you record the audio separately and
Well, this is how I do it anyway
You record this audio separately and then you pilot your mech to lip-syncing. Okay?
What's the first order of business ink yourself? That's that's like rule number one of a reefing
You can be as shameless as you like you can be
I was cumbers you like
and
But first order of business we ink in this house
We've come in
But then what you do is you record an MOV fail of your model your mech lip-syncing to the short
And then you send off to the editor
I'm peeling back the curtains. Okay, ink and vomit pretty simple. Yeah, when I'm offline you have to vomit
Closest I can do is pee myself. That'll do that'll do I
Mean if we really want to start getting into the debate of a squirt pee
Yes, so after a my little script writing stream I
I'm gonna pilot my mech to all the
Pre-recorded shorts I have which is a living which is a lot for me for a beam
Oh
Why did I come into um, I rage quit slime rancher and
I'm reading marshmallows now, but I'm eating quickly because I forgot to eat yesterday
Gonna be honest, maybe that weight loss isn't so unbelievable now that I've
Realized that I go days without eating. I just get so distracted and I don't feel hungry
Like what happened that made you rage quit. I just suck at the game
Mmm, I'm just not very good
My slime rancher is officially the second blink it took me to the fourth month of streaming to quit my second game
Yeah, I don't know why I don't have hunger queues at the minute. Um, I
Can't think I'm not that stressed. I mean
stress is straight like stress is one thing, but
To not have hunger chews is something else
And do we need to make sure you eat honestly? Sorry, I'm choking on the cheese string. Can you hear it in my throat?
Your cheese is in my throat. What are you gonna do about it?
I'm picked into no, I raged off Pikmin because I killed so many of you at the bridge
If you
Didn't get the opportunity to see the Pikmin stream. It was a really fun game. I enjoyed it
The fucking flamingos. I don't know what I was supposed to do all years drowned at the bridge
I think we lost like 50 soldiers at a bridge of water. I
Never want to hear that
String cheese does slap pretty hard. Literally. I'm stringing it up right now and eating it. I'm watching
Space Marine 2
Everyone keeps saying that I'm gonna have to look into everyone keeps saying space marine 2 for a stream snip game. I have and
Have rock and storm I
Have a mines of Moria, which I've never played before I'm gonna be playing it with you for the first time
stream sniping up
Blues assist drowning pick well clearly not
I
Don't think they were supposed to drown on that bridge
Refresh strongy of the marshmallow. What is your wisdom my today's wisdom is?
My shoulder
Remember to eat and sleep when you need to well I got plenty of sleep. I can assure you I got plenty of sleep
13 hours plus sleep
Yeah, I didn't expect to sleep that long either, but um, yeah, I just kind of kept snoozing my alarm
And then have to was when I woke up
Super excited for the donut on I've been putting in some OT overtime and went
To Gamble for the funds knock it off reflend
Knock it off. Did I hear rock and stone? Yeah, we're gonna do
We're also gonna do left for dead to campaign
Fantastic, sorry, I'm looking for my blanket, but I don't have it and my legs are cold
and my legs are cold and
I'm on my chair
reading some
I always wanted to try Pikmin Pikmin is really cute, but I died and then I read quite on it, so
But yeah, we're doing left for dead to stream step and finish in the campaign together because it was so good
Did you have any dreams during the 13 hours? No, whenever I sleep long, I never remember any dreams
At all. Hey, strongy. How are you getting along with the collar?
It doesn't even feel like I'm wearing it right now. Like it just feels
Comfortable, it's natural. It was in fact not a joke. Wait, what did I joke about?
Wait, what did I joke about?
That I forgot to eat. No, that's very true
That that cheese string is the first thing I ate since I had to shriek to to
chicken crimpy
shapes at the start of the stream yesterday when I was munching I
Forgot the rope
I already broke it. Since you tried slime wrench or two, I suggest you want to try more Stardew Valley. Oh
Thank you very much for your suggestion reflin. I understand Stardew Valley is a very nice and casual game
That game would be so fucking boring to stream
I cannot even put into words how boring I would be during that stream
There are other streamers that are much more capable of playing Stardew Valley
I am not someone that is that interest and I can make Stardew Valley fun. Okay, I
Don't I've never finished it
I've played it for a couple of hours and called it a day and I'm like this isn't a game for me
I need and you start a little bit more juicy, you know, unless you can stream snipe me in it
Then there's a whole other kettle of fish, but as it stands
I believe Azura is playing Stardew Valley so you can watch her VODs on it. She's very
Interesting have I tried Undertale?
Yeah, I tried to do a pacifist run and then I got stuck at the fucking fish
She wouldn't let me go. So in her mechanic
This is spoilers for Undertale if you want to do a pacifist run in her mechanic
You have to run away mid fight and she kept catching me and I kept running out of HP
Eh, I forget that chat can make context if I call. That's what I need you need to like put in brackets
This is in context of this. Hello, mommy. You playing a slime themed game means slime to girl confirmed for gen 2
I'm joking. Please don't hurt me. I love you. Yes
You do love me, don't you? So don't ever ask for slime again
I'm not gonna sling girl. I've already told you what one of the girls are so do with that what you will
Have a- Oh, right. I've confirmed one type of girl. I've put a trail on and off for the other kinds of girls
Whether or not any of yous have picked up one that is the whole Azura Stardew Streams turned into a Yapathon
Oh, did she not play it? Was she just talking?
I don't like Stardew that much. I like Rune Factory more. Yeah, Strony Rage put in a slime game
It seems very in character. Exactly. See that me fling no sleeping
Hi Strony
I'm sad I can't say for the stream. No, don't worry. The streamer shite. I have to pull my transition out of my car
So I just want it. Oh your car is trans congrats. So sorry. Shut the fuck up. That was a pathetic joke
So I just wanted to say love what you've been doing in your free time if you get the chance to listen to these songs
Rush by Aira star link-up remix by Neyo and Fabolo. So just a pineapple by Boyle. What?
What interest in making me choose?
We can always just make Strony a slime. Absolutely not. I am not spending fucking XY elemental p sending a message to Nari being like
I got paid this much to turn me in a slime. No
Not happening
Strony, how do you always lose things you use daily?
No, I couldn't find so in order to record in order
Stop. I don't know. Are you squinting me?
I promise it'll patch you on the head when you are finished. You need your strength to in call the shots
I'll make you a deal
I'll make you a deal from the five minutes
It'll take me to set up the membership stream after this stream. I will
And this is scouts honor. I will go make uh, I'll heat up some chicken. How about that?
How about that? I'll heat up some chicken. I got a chicken parma
a
leftover
It's a Hawaiian chicken parma. It's delicious. Got pineapple and ham on it. I'm gonna heat that up and I'm gonna eat it. Okay
Checking. Oh, it's delicious chicken parmas are just fucking godlike right hydration check refling
Ham on it. I mean
It's stuck in my throat
Why was that so stuck? I've never heard that before. Oh, it was fighting back. Holy shit
Ham on me. I made a small guide on how to easily remove steam friends after a stream stipend event
Go to friends go to manage friends list remove
friend
Okay, that looks a lot more efficient than what the heck I was in
Just shouting a request into the void
But you got to do some spicy puppy ASMR roleplay your panning makes me feral
I don't know if one of these words will be all flagged and slapped down. Oh, well, that would be amazing kisses kisses. Oh, yeah
You like my pan
refling
Autistic girlfriend lego win soon. I am
Waking up before stream two hours before stream so I can start wapping out these like things that I want to do
Um, as I said, I've finally it took me how long to do the tapping on keychains ASMR
I've finally done it today and I those key chains arrived like a month ago
Uh, but the editors are all now in place so I can just throw in my little edits tiki
Oh
Hi momet further to all of the talk about being intimidated by you
It took me a while to openly write as much as I do in chat and interact with you
I started with feeling like I may say the wrong thing and uh and offend you or worse make you disappointed in you. No
I'm a brain bleh. You don't have to worry about me even now that I know you how accepting and how much of a degenerate
me a degenerate
refling
Never
I'll write a little bit just a wee bit
Uh
Right, where were you degenerate? Let me find the d word. Uh, I am still worried that I might go too far
Or don't make it obvious. I'm simply teasing not trying to be mean which something causes me to stay my tongue and remain silent
um
Get that booth running through and my tongue isn't soft until your chocolate cavern is clean. What?
Uh
Ironically brightens my day when I say make do something that makes you happy my heart gets a warm and fuzzy
But the opposite is true
If I think I've upset you my heart dropped so low that I think I've hit rock bottom
Hope that shed some more light on why some people want to be silent. Love you go bar. I love you too refling
No, I know people seem to think you're gonna offend me or whatever. I'm like, how can you offend me?
Please how unless you're just straight up insulting me. How on earth am I supposed gonna take it as a fence?
I think
Like if you think about what your majority of your message structure are, let's be honest
We're being a naughty naughty together, right?
So I think it would be hard to like unless you're going to be like
Uh, you're you're 50 kilograms. That's too heavy for me. Like
You're just so like fat and obese or whatever. It's not like that. I'm like, okay, then
I'm not sure where that came from
But like it's really hard to I can't imagine how you can accidentally insult me though
I think it's conditioning from past streamers
Let's try this tariel should have never been added to a movie. Hmm
Right, let's just find that message put user in time out 10 seconds. Okay, right. There we go. Uh, anyway moving on
Um, really like really have to go now. Thank you for the stream. You liked it. It was shit
You like the stream
You like oh, I mean, thank you very much. Have a good day by woman by reflin. You like that
I'm gonna make sure I redirect into sheepsters. Um, let's see she be caught in the
What is she be up to what shenanigans is she be up to today?
She be is
Not streaming today, so I can't redirect into her
Okay, so she's not strumming right
You were struggling in a very funny way to be fair. No, she was she be took us on a field trip earlier on
cruising on that school bus
and then
Emmy's out the game for five more days. So then it would go a zero delay next
Are she not got her rooms up?
Hmm, I have a message of zero right now and just feel like hello darling, right? You guys get to listen to
A real conversation ready. Hello
Darling just wanted to know if you have your thumbnails to put your
Strings up for it
icky icky
And I put a little oowoo at the end oowoo. Just so she knows it's not pass of the grass
I mean, I get worried the girls read my messages as a demand rather than just being like, hey, I don't know where this is
Oh, I thought the hobbit was lord of the rings it is it's um the pre lord of the rings part
if you will right okay, and then it's uh
That was her name mercy modis
Mercy modis more like mercy throw in the fleets. Holy shit. Is she okay?
Process of elimination gorilla, I'm really gonna finish this dot dot dot. Did she finish it?
Wait, there's no veil remember going up today. Are you serious?
I can't redirect into anyone
It's over
Uh, wait, are you streaming today?
Is there a streaming today?
Oh my gosh, there's no one
I'm the only not maybe the only one that fucking waited. I see stream today at least
And before I was the only one that streamed and it ended up with me rage quit in a child's game
That's embarrassing. Please tell me ac streamed. Okay
Please tell me ac streamed
That's embarrassing that's fucking embarrassing. I'm so sorry
I've tainted the spark of fun
I feel
There's no way I can't believe it the girls are working against me. Fuck it. We'll redirect into den for she seems to be up
Don't go. I'm gonna put don't go offline you slag. Um, oh no, don't call her that what the fuck
She doesn't know me like that. Don't go offline. Please. I want to redirect into you. Let me just make sure she's not going off
All right, hold on. Let me just make sure she didn't go offline
Please tell me she's still streaming. I know you can hear her a little bit in the background
Hold on video game. Be quiet. Say that silence your tongue video game
That fuck is the audio setting get off
Okay
See the work is she going offline? Wait, this is a premiere
Oh my god, it's not a live stream
I'm an idiot. It's not a live stream, right? No one's gonna redirect it into them. It's not a live stream
That's embarrassing. I've closed the tab off. I hope I hope dempa doesn't see that that's embarrassing
That is absolutely mortifying. Sorry. I'm not fucking
That's embarrassing. I just tried to fucking redirect into a
Right, thank you
Thank you
And you wrote are you even wrote it in chat, bro? I closed that tab so fast. I'm not looking
I'm not looking. That's not me. You can't prove it
Um
Katerina's live did she just go live right? Let me redirect into Katarina. I don't see her
Oh, she's on the adoption though
I don't think you're supposed to redirect into collabs because it's like, oh, thank you so much for the video
Like
Oh, fuck it. We'll just we'll just no redirect and then we'll maybe know how you can go. Um
I've got weird error message. Sorry if this is a repeat
I just remember you said you got a picture of your tear when you left a mark on it. Oh, do you want that?
I mean if you want to show
Give me a few give me an hour to cook and it's all yours
and
I would rather hug her
Hi mom, how'd you do my tasteful? That is good
Love a good tasteful. I don't mean to offend but I want you to suffocate me with your thighs
Offend I encourage
You want me to watch napoleon dynamite and talladega nights. I've actually seen talladega nights
I've never seen napoleon dynamite before
Before you go later. Wait, why thank lord we thank you for the fiver literally
Oh, thank you
Uh leader alligator in a wild crocodile
Um, I know you said you take inspiration from demper from the ace thing and I also watched the video
But what is she doing there? I genuinely don't know. I'm a dumb
She shoved it in her fanny
I don't know how other way to say that
Listen to the audio and where do you think she put it?
Refland I know we share one brain cell, but what do you think happened?
Why do you think chat does he know does he know? I don't know if refland knows
Mummy naked dog is up for all the script delays for a win. I don't have clothes for it
I don't have a yukata to put on the side like I don't have clothes that look like me
I
I'll commission the artwork, but I don't think I can actually do it
Mummy can I get a feel over of kissing on youtube? Yeah
I might be doing a youtube milestone stream, which is 10 000 kisses
Are you wanting it already dear bifling?
You get 10 000 kisses and every burp puts his back by one kiss
Could just be my biohazard hoodie honestly
Yes, we tested it in a membership stream. So I it takes me one hour to do
1 000 kisses, but if I zoom through it like
So 20k no the 20k celebration is tinga
I'm doing what ac did
The 20k celebration is vengabus. Oh wait. No the 20k celebration was the work. It's like 25k celebration
is vengabus
And then 30k was gonna be rebecca cosplay, but I can't find um
A high quality cosplay I want yet. So I might have to stall the rebecca and make it 30k is 10 000 kisses
the machine gun goes
Have you ever tried playing the game cassette beats if you like pokemon you might enjoy it. It's different unique take on it
Hmm
No 20k kisses because of all the burps putting her back honestly, uh
Anywhere I can send a pdf
Uh, you don't have enough characters here to send you our marriage certificate that you need to sign. That's so cute
I didn't expect that
You're already being knotted by not eating properly now. You have a color on you have a bark jet bark, but
I'm not gonna lie. That gave me a pulse
Uh
What the fuck
Monkey that's bad that should not get me so easily
That that should not get me so easy
Take care of yourself and in turn the refunds will take care of cooking and tucking me in a bed. Oh, that's so cute
Mummy how close to the farm would slime rancher be would we be free range?
Would not even be putting cages. I think if you were naughty, there has to be some form of punishment
I think like facing would be a good one
Please breathe quietly or during the member stream
Oh
Okay, okay, I understand. Okay. I read it quietly. We need to gift you a headset with poppy ears
Um, I don't think
Strani you mentioned maybe doing some pop-up membership script right in streams to get caught up. Yeah, you'll never guess what comes up next
Um punishment equals no milking. Yeah, you're not allowed to talk to a face
Uh, the only way I accept death is in between your thighs. Yeah
Is that a punishment though? Yeah, if I say you're being denoured
access denied
Access denied
Oh, did I say thank you grim baby alert for the trip? I've been really really bad
Please mommy. Yes, I will right
we're not gonna redirect into anyone because
Uh, there's no one a veal or that's fucking online today. I'm about to jump into a membership stream. Um
And then I'll far
Uh
Being denied a doesn't sound you may are you gonna go stream you may go stream right now on youtube so I can redirect into
Do you stream? Are you on twitch only? I think you're on twitch only, aren't you?
Oh, you may are you on twitter? Do you stream on youtube?
Uh, no, you don't stream on youtube get farted on
I'm needing something to redirect into
But you're not online. I don't stream on youtube. No, you didn't that's right bend over for the spanking
That's right. No, you didn't you didn't you don't know you're not farted on
Simcasting on twitter news, honestly, right. I'm gonna wrap it up. I do apologize for such a short stream
I'm afraid that that is the risk we take when I play a game for the first time
Left or dead to playing it for the first time. Absolute bliss
Perfection gorgeous 10 out of 10 experience
slime rancher
The child's game has defeated me. I admit it. I admit it. I am a shicer gamer. Okay
um
You may just got members you're gonna listen and
Oh fine. I'll bend over
Right. Thank you so so much. Um, I will see you tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow
for some
Very sus ASMR roleplay
I'm actually gonna have to change the title to our roleplay because I'm going to be using the smd for it
This microphone here you hear me hitting you
That's what this microphone is. It's not ASMR
So I need to take that out of the title
But I am doing ASMR hand cam stream
The girls did swap out their ASMRs because they were a bit worried, but I'm sticking to my guns because
Yeah, youtube admitted that the rat strike didn't count
So I'm like, do I need to tell emmy to beg?
A little a little bit begging begging for a peggling on twitter to remove the other strike now
Because it seems to be working
somehow
Uh, but yes
Hmm
Please 18 plus game god gamer, please children games challenge impossible honestly though
I can't even see my figure out. Like I just can't even get it
Just doesn't happen
Rats are not 18 plus real
um
Right
DEMPA why aren't you streaming?
I tried to I was about to redirect into your premiere thing
I said what I said
It's I know I was I fucking spoke in it and thought you were streaming
I literally spoke in it like don't go offline. I'm redirecting them to you xoxo
And then someone was like it's a premiere and I was like, oh
So I closed it out of embarrassment. I didn't want to read. I have been streaming on here. I know that's why I thought
I was like, oh you're live. I'm gonna redirect into you, but you're not live
Wet fart
I might switch to youtube, but I'm scared
I'm scared of you too
A little bit twitch little bit of you change
I did I replied to it on monk eyes. I fucking closed that so quickly when I realized it was a premiere
I was like, that's embarrassing
That's embarrassing
That is mortifying. I'm so mortified
Why did she be tweet out strongy add furry art to donut on rewards right now? What?
Hello, hello, she be hello
Hello
Stony would you be a furry? No, I'm in a pet play, but I'd rather line up for it
The bun wants what the bun wants like she can have what she wants
Hmm
I'll give the tweet a like but I'm giving it a side eye as well
I want to real number one. You got to keep the talents happy if they want furry art
I mean, I guess we can get furry art. We're gonna refer to it as far art. Yeah, exactly
What would your persona be as a wrestler the thigh crusher something like that
Fur
I guess the one who should have said that I'm not a furry wasn't icy, but she's doing
Food allure
It's all about the feet. Oh feet a lot. No, you fit foot allure
We directing on youtube is so confusing. I think it's a wee bit rough, but once you get it, you get it
Right, I'm gonna wrap it up. Wrap it up. I'm gonna very quickly get bite to eat and then we're gonna finish this motherfucking
Scripts that I need to send to these poor girls. I've been waiting forever to do these collab audios with
Mmm foot allure confirmed. I think she be said she wanted to fucking weaned us at one point and I was like
I
Okay
Butta is based but I meant feet though short allure right you're done. You're done. Nah, you're done
No more. Look. Am I already fulfilled short allure after her little accident? Okay
I shan't be hearing none of it. I shan't be hearing none of it. You're done. Wrap it up. Wrap it up in the stream
Ding ding ding ding
Wait, that was real. Didn't you not see the clip and everything?
We Emmy had an accident
I thought she was joking. No, that's why she asked you would you still love her?
Hyena girl confirmed for Gentoo. Honestly, I'd be down for a hyena girl
Slam allure the only agency we need done ban
Uh, I like my wife's
That's amazing
Aren't there new pictures? Oh, I never retweeted it. I never retweeted it
Uh
Scatman be zoo right enough
Someone called her be soup and I was like do not speak for the rest of the evening
Do not call my darling little sister be
soup
I won't be having it
Medusa girl for gents like she makes you rock hard
I'm okay like that
Mmm be soup like be like a bumblebee be
I know what you want from me
Right, I'm ending it. I'm gonna go do a member stream and then tomorrow it is public asmr and
Sorry public role play. I'm gonna give hypnosis another
Another bang for my buck. No, don't end it. Wait, are you going live on youtube? DEMPA?
Are you going live on youtube? Yes or no? I will fart in your mouth. I will fart in your eyelashes
Please do not think you're not under scene by me
No, I'm not I was making a joke. Oh, oh
Oh
Reflings
tickle dempo
I'm purr. What do you mean you're purr? You don't have to stream on you. What you don't have to pay to stream on youtube
You're purr
You need to spend money to stream on youtube
Cease her at once tickle her pickle
I will my see you. No, I mean for being a member. No
Right, we're having three different conversations here at once. All right. I'm going to
Wrap it up. I'm gonna get a bite to eat and you guys can listen to me munch on some chicken
Eh mods pay for that dent with membership tickle didn't tickle dental now
Oh my god, that was it wedding
It's not wedding dance. What was it in austin powers where it was like, oh
Do the wedding wedding tackle. Oh my god
reeflings
Give give dempo a wedding tackle
Give her a dentist tickle
For not streaming
Right, I will see you alligators tomorrow or if you're a member I'll see you in five minutes once I'm rested up
I do apologize for such a shy so stream today. That was not my intention
It was cute at first
But then it was like blocked off blocked off blocked off. I'm like, all right. Wrap it up. Wrap it up
I get it. It's blocked off wrap it up
Wrap it up
But that's just my preference and play style
Um, and that's why we're playing left or dead to stream snake shortly
Because it's got a good taste. I like it
Thank you rich credit to thank you. Right. I'm not the only one that he's
See you on the other side. Thank you
Right. I'll see you tomorrow. Bye. Bye. I give you kisses for every slime we unlocked, which was like
Neckle rock, honey. I think it was like eight or something
I just realized if you say rock and honey right away, it kind of sounds like
one seven kisses
Like 11
question mark
literally
unironically
Seven question mark
I don't know. I don't know how to go. Hello. I'll see you tomorrow. Bye. Bye or see you in five minutes depending on the
Shesh and okay. I'll give you
See you tomorrow. Bye. Bye